. I have something really interesting for
you today.
Asa Hutchinson is the Republican governor
of Arkansas.
He's a 70 year old white, lifelong conservative
dude.
Right.
He's not the picture of progressivism, but
there is one area in which Asa Hutchinson's
traditional conservatism overlaps with progressive
social ideas.
And it's on small L libertarianism.
OK, the progressive view being let people
do what they want and be who they are without
interference from the government, particularly
when they are issues where we talk to medical
experts.
We don't need people like Asa Hutchinson telling
us what to do, overlapping with the conservative
view, which is government should only be involved
in anything when there's really a specific
reason for government involvement.
It's not government should take a position
on everything.
It's we shouldn't even be involved in a lot
of things unless there's a really good reason
to do so.
Government doesn't have to have a say in everything.
That's exactly the reasoning for why Republican
Governor Asa Hutchinson vetoed a bill from
the Arkansas House and Senate, which would
ban gender affirming treatments for transgender
minors in the state of Arkansas.
Now, unfortunately, Asa Hutchinson's veto
was overridden by the state, House and Senate,
but Hutchinson has made his view clear.
The bill is too extreme and the new law will
have devastating repercussions for transgender
youth who are already undergoing various medical
treatments in passing the Save Adolescents
from Experimentation Act.
This is what they're calling it.
Arkansas became the first state to pass a
bill restricting access to gender affirming
health care for anyone under 18, even with
parental consent.
Other states have similar bills working their
way through legislatures.
So Hutchinson goes on Tucker Carlson show
last night.
It's actually fascinating to watch because
the governor explains how his conservatism
is what led him to veto the bill.
And Tucker just looks confused.
He does his confused face.
He seems unable to understand it or unwilling.
And at first, Tucker won't even let the governor
answer the question.
Take a look.
Terzian in the most sensitive issues and so
sure, why would sign why are we regulating
the behavior of children at all if we're allowing
children to decide?
And by the way, I read a study today that
showed the overwhelming majority of kids who
do not take life altering hormones in the
end decide not to, quote, transition to a
new sex.
So there's a lot going on here.
But I'm asking is, as a conservative, you
just incited invoked Ronald Reagan as if he
were for chemical castration of children.
What other behaviors should we not use the
power of the state to regulate among kids
seriously?
Well, every time.
And look, Tucker, you want to keep talking.
You want me to answer a question sincerely
whenever you do.
Well, thank you.
And so.
Whenever you whether it's it's beer for minors,
these are all issues that you have to address
the legislature, you make judgment calls on
it.
But we also try to restrain ourselves as conservatives
and say we don't have to be involved in every
issue.
And if you want to broaden the party, if you
want to get back to the principles, then let's
at least think through in a reasoned way as
to whether this is the right bill to interfere
with parents and doctors.
Decisions on a health care matter, as you
pointed out, has does not have thorough research
in every area.
This is an actual conservative principle.
We don't need to be involved in every issue
now.
I am not praising this because I would agree
with him about every issue in which the government
should or should not be involved.
But the Republican Party has abandoned this
supposed value, anti-war weakness, owning
the libs guns on the House floor.
None of this stuff is real traditional conservatism
as it used to exist, recognizing that they
don't have to be involved in every issue,
even if they don't like what some people are
doing.
That is a conservative value.
Let's continue.
And so I yield to that.
Whatever you look at this bill, in my view,
to the lack of research really quick, 10 years
ago, if somebody had said, hey, Asa Hutchinson,
you're being governor of Arkansas and you're
going to veto a bill that would have protected
children from chemical castration, what do
you think you would have said?
Well, just like I said today, if you're talking
about a reassignment surgery, I would have
signed that bill in a minute.
But whenever you're talking about maybe less
than two hundred kids in Arkansas that's currently
on hormone treatment and they are immediately
cut off without having a grandfather clause
in this legislation, I don't think that's
treating those kids or their parents or their
health care providers fairly or equally.
All right, that's the conservative position.
Governor, thanks, I appreciate coming on.
Tucker here is ridiculing the idea that this
is a conservative position that Asa Hutchinson
is espousing.
But it is Hutchinson says the science is unclear
on some of this.
That's absolutely true.
It is without a doubt true that the science
is not yet clear about the benefits and risks
of adolescent transitions that maybe with
or without medication, with or without surgery,
it's undeniable.
I'm not even taking a position on that.
It is still early in that process of figuring
out what is good and what is not so good for
different people.
But if that's the case, you don't say, well,
then government decides that would be more
reason to say, let's leave this in the medical
science community, even though it's still
being researched, medical science knows more
than Asa Hutchinson.
That's the important principle here.
And if it's as unclear as Asa Hutchinson says,
and it's still something being investigated.
Why would politicians decide instead of doctors?
It makes no sense.
It is the conservative position.
And unless there's a really good reason and
a body of evidence for politicians to get
involved, just stay the hell out of it.
And that is exactly what Asa Hutchinson is
saying.
It's an actual conservative position.
And Tucker's confusion about it or maybe feigned
confusion, that's really anger confirms to
us once again that Tucker Carlson's faux populism,
there's nothing conservative about it.
Fundamentally, nicely done by Asa Hutchinson.
And as far as you know, went as far as the
science, as far as what should or shouldn't
be legal or at what age or with or without
parental consent, these are things that the
medical community will figure out and is researching.
We don't need to imagine what is conservative
about thinking that you need the Arkansas
state legislature and state Senate involved
in something with which medical science is
now exploring and researching.
It's delusional and it's certainly not conservative.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.